at a time when most New Yorkers are
staying home this warehouse is bustling
with workers they once made signs and
displays for major fashion houses but
now they have a new job producing face
shields used by medical personnel
treating coronavirus patients their boss
Mike de Gaulle couldn't be prouder
there's government programs for people
who are unemployed everyone's can making
a choice right now and there they're
making a choice to come here and do
something to help our first responders
who are doing amazing things less than
one week after the mayor put out a
desperate call for supplies of dugal and
partner Bednar we're shipping their
first order it is inspiring to see how
quickly people figured out a way to do
something that was needed and not just
do it in a small way but do it in a very
big way
de Gaulle is one of several companies at
this industrial complex alone
that's retooled its operation in
response to the coronavirus now the city
wants to produce test kits locally as
well as productive gear
experts say millions more tests will be
needed to make sure it's safe for
everyone to go back to work and school
this lab in Indiana donated 50 thousand
to New York hospitals now it's under
contract to sell that many per week to
the city and is helping to establish
more local production facilities if you
template this across the country to a
couple major cities this country can
very very easily make a couple million
of these swabs and kids a week working
in the midst of a pandemic does require
precautions like these temperature
checks when employees show up to work
most say they're thankful to still have
a paycheck in addition to just not
wanting to spend time at home and be you
know idle it's so nice to be able to
give back giving back and getting by but
hardly business as usual
Kristen salumi al Jazeera New York